you better get your overwatch games in
now because Blizzard is putting the beta
on hold the company announced today that
the hiatus will last until sometime in
January the extended break as Blizzard
describes it in a blog post comes after
more than a month of testing with the
closed beta having opened in late
October since then more than 900,000
games have been played providing
blizzard with large amounts of raw data
and feedback from fans Blizzard said the
phase of development has been key but
now it's time to analyze the data we
have dig into your feedback even further
and put the knowledge to use as best we
can it'll do this by temporarily
shutting down the beta on Thursday
December 10th at 9am PSC during this
downtime we're looking forward to making
more improvements to the game as well as
continuing to work on in development
features like spectating and progression
Blizzard explains the plan is for the
closed beta to return mid to late
January everyone currently in the beta
will still have access then and more
people will be added to that test
however Blizzard says the exact timing
and how many players are invited will be
determined by our testing needs if
you're hoping to get in before the break
begins next week you are unfortunately
out of luck Blizzard won't be adding any
additional players to the current pool
of testers before things wrap up
Blizzard revealed in November that in
addition to PC overwatch will be coming
to Xbox one and ps4 surprisingly we also
learned that the game will not as
expected be free to play instead it will
be available as a more traditional paid
game there won't be cross-platform play
across PC and consoles due to the
advantage computer players might have
you